if you have the power to come back from
the dead what would you do your former
mentor is a revolutionist killer and
you're going to have to help your worst
enemy in order to take him down i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat sato
in ajin season two time here there's a
slight error in the script we changed
the name from k in season one of ajin to
now nagai in season two or as griff
would say nagai so sorry about that
these two kids caught nagai and nakano
will be forced into taking down the most
dangerous revolutionist in the world
sato aka the man in the hat these kids
have been discovered to be a jinn which
are types of humans who cannot die and
can summon these black ghosts to do
whatever they want these two are running
from this guy called tosaki who is an
expert ajin killer and has just been
ordered by his boss to hunt down sato
sato wants to make ajins legal in japan
but since the government has ignored his
wishes he's now made a list of 15
powerful people in japan who are against
his kind and will begin killing them one
by one until he gets what he wants
meanwhile these ajin kids continue to be
on the run with no clue of what to do
next when suddenly nagai finds out on
his phone that the guy they're running
away from tosaki his wife is in a deep
coma and so the two pay revisit and tell
tosaki exactly where they're going
forcing them to meet up with him face to
face to make a deal the guy tells a
trigger happy tosaki that they should
team up to take down the one person who
made both their lives miserable sato
himself and they agreed to team up okay
we all know the phrase the enemy of my
enemy is my friend but dang has anybody
forgotten what he has put us through
what our own government has put us
through he works for the government to
hunt down a gin and then torture them in
the name of science till we die and then
come back to life again and again for
profit using what they discovered from
our mangled bodies to advance technology
in medicine and warfare this guy's about
as trustful as the og glasses guy is
with a cell phone camera we can't trust
this guy at all but no guy is right
about the fact that we're just a couple
of ajin kids with no money resources or
practical training really in combating
sato which means we need to think smart
and long term however i wouldn't have
relied on tosaki's good faith into
believing us and teaming up with us
because that was a risky move and he
could have easily turned down our offer
and captured us on the spot in a much
more perfect situation i would have
tried to gain some good faith with him
before approaching tosaki and would have
tried to capture another bad guy that
they're chasing around to show him that
we mean business and are serious about
making a deal with him however that
wouldn't have been realistic we
literally have no money or resources in
finding sato or his henchmen but the
least they could have done was not rush
into meeting tosaki because nagai found
out through his hacking skills
information on tosaki and that his wife
has been in a coma for ages which means
using her as bait to lure tosaki was
perfect however that guy had no real
reason to rush into calling tosaki as
soon as he found out about his wife's
whereabouts in setting up a meeting
where tensions are high it's important
to establish a point of contact that the
initiator is familiar with the guy
proposing the terms should always try to
set the meeting on a familiar home term
however and a guy just rushed into it
setting up a meeting with tosaki where
his wife was which he no doubt has been
too many times before and is more
familiar with the layout than the guy
was the least this stupid kid could have
done was to check out the hospital first
get familiar with the layout and its
escape entrances the vent systems and so
on even if all of this took a while
cause remember we're all alone and
tosaki isn't going after our family
anymore to find us we can take our sweet
time to make sure we set things up right
the guy in nakano joined with tosaki and
his aegen hunter task force and they
watch sato declare on the news that he's
already begun killing the people on his
list which means they don't have much
time to waste tosaki then begins
training them and sees that a guy is
better suited to being the brains of the
operation and nakano the muscle they
meet with this famous ajin doctor who
tosaki and his men kidnapped earlier and
he asks to see nagai's black ghost the
guy tells the doctor that his ghost
doesn't follow orders does the opposite
of whatever he says and goes on
autopilot after a while doing his own
thing if the guy doesn't keep him under
control the ajin doctor then suspects
that because his ghost is so dense and
doesn't listen to his orders that this
is related to the mind and ego of the
owner of the black ghost meaning that if
nagai wants to fix his broken black
ghost he needs to fix himself first
because this kid has got some serious
anger issues against everybody and it's
seriously messing with his powers
elsewhere sato gets ready to kill his
next target and asks his crew to put him
in this full makeup outfit because what
he's about to do will shock the world he
arrives at this airport sneaks through
security and gets on the plane he sits
down seeing nearby what he's come for
his next target the plane takes off not
knowing everyone on this plane is
already dead now high in the sky sato
gets up and heads to business class he
kills this guy and these other two
bodyguards terrifying the [ __ ] out of
this lady as his black ghost kills the
next victim on his kill list he then
detonates the bomb that he brought with
him on the plane causing the whole thing
to come crashing down forcing every
innocent human being on board with him
to die okay this proves my earlier point
we don't have time to mess around yes
training to use their black ghost is
important but the training regiment that
tosaki has for these kids is actually
very smart because despite having powers
working out in general can provide the
user with many benefits that will spill
over into everyday life from reducing
stress levels to improving sharper
memory and thinking and also improving
your overall cognitive function and
after what the ajin doctor said the
performance of a degens black ghost is
highly based on the mental and emotional
state of the ajin himself the guy is a
smart kid but he's only as good as his
ability to control himself in combat and
a large chunk of this will come down to
his mental state in fact tosaki should
have taken this one step further and
included mental drills commonly used on
soldiers in order to help them prepare
for the trauma of combat that they will
face such as working on controlling
aggressive thoughts relaxation and cut
down on destructive emotions that can
plague the user's mind basically getting
comfortable at being uncomfortable the
guy knows that he has problems
controlling his black ghost because he
himself is not fully stable at least
stable enough to be able to control his
black ghost effectively so rather than
relying on the guy to simply work on
himself tosaki should have someone help
work on a guy's mental insights as well
because working on the fundamental
characteristics of stress regulation and
mental stability is just as important as
the physical and they need all the help
that they can get back at the base the
guy walks into this room and sees his
co-workers aim their guns at him and he
lets out his agent scream which
instantly knocks them out but nakano
comes out pissed as hell and tells him
that they were just teaching him how to
shoot the guy tells him that they can't
trust anybody anywhere nakano thinks
nagai is acting crazy and they're then
told by the group that sato has just
killed the next person on his kill list
this pisses nagai off and he runs into
the forest to figure out his black ghost
in the woods his black ghost starts
trying to kill him and doesn't listen to
anything the guy says freaking him the
hell out as his black ghost goes
absolutely nuts on a tree nagai is too
battle-hardened for his own good and his
angry emotions are messing everything up
later tosaki gets everyone together and
tells them that based on his research
sato will most likely kill this guy next
the labor minister who has gone into
hiding which means that they have time
to prepare for sato's attack but sato
manages to find out the minister's
location and he sends his finest ajin
death hunter to go after the minister
causing more horrors and more deaths to
rack up as he kills the minister and
everyone else trying to protect him with
brutal ease tosaki later gets word about
this and realizes that sato is far more
deadly than they thought and tells the
team to speed up their training and he
tells nagai to hurry up and fix himself
and his black ghost because it still
doesn't listen to anything then a guy
tells it more days pass by and they get
word that sato has killed another person
on his kill list nakano begins freaking
out saying out loud what everybody is
thinking they don't have much time left
before sato kills everyone on his list
and more trouble comes their way because
the department of defense asks tosaki to
come in for a chat they're investigating
the death of this famous ajin doctor the
same one that tosaki kidnapped and faked
his death to cover their tracks because
the only way to stop sato will be with
the help of this ajin doctor elsewhere
in this prison sits blond guy nagai's
ex-best friend and who helped nagai
escape when he first discovered his
aegen powers he willingly went to prison
for nagai this guy is best friend goals
and has a heart of gold i'm not even
kidding and he helps this series face
dude with some prison thugs which causes
serious face dude to save his life and
we discover the blonde hair guy has now
become best friends in prison with a
flying ajin later on back at the base
the group trains for the fight to come
and tosaki keeps tabs on one of the most
important people on the list this
minister and his whereabouts they find
out that this minister will hold a
meeting with the vice minister in a few
days to discuss new government plans
against sato the group prepares to catch
sato during that meeting and come up
with an idea to find out the location of
the meeting by stealing the minister's
schedule however this man and woman sent
by the department of defense don't give
a damn about their plans and asks tosaki
to meet with them they think that the
famous ajin doctor isn't actually dead
and believe that tosaki has something to
do with it tosaki denies everything and
walks out and later sends in black hair
girl to steal the minister's schedule by
using some crafty agent tricks and she
later takes a peek at the thumb drive
while waiting tosaki gets kidnapped by
the same man and woman from earlier
burying a needle into his neck and
forcing him to pass out blackhair girl
shows up late to the party releasing her
black ghost to fight them but is shocked
to see a different black ghost from
another ajin from this girl okay this is
why black hair girl should not have
snuck a peek at that thumb drive the
department of defense is breathing down
our necks about the ajin doctor that
tosaki kidnapped so we can't afford any
mistakes this ajin doctor is an american
biophysicist who is world renowned about
his scientific outlook on ajins and he
knows how black ghosts are formed and
even the science behind their existence
both the american and japanese
government are aware of the existence of
agents and have a research agreement
sharing info about a jinns between the
two nations which means that this guy is
probably the most important guy around
here when it comes to agents and based
on the research agreement between japan
and the us and the fact that the ajin
doctor has dual citizenship with the us
tusaki should have figured out way
earlier that the country of freedom and
bald eagles would have come knocking on
his door eventually and because of this
he should have worked better at erasing
every single speck of evidence that day
he kidnapped the ajin doctor because up
until now tosaki has had ample head
start on this which he chose not to take
advantage of also the assignment was to
steal the minister's schedule it was not
to open the thumb drive right within the
compound itself there surely would have
been cameras around which means that
blackhair girl just risked the entire
operation by being way too curious and
taking a peek at the thumb drive before
she got back to the car and if she
hadn't done this she could have had a
better chance at getting to tosaki
before he got injected curiosity killed
the cat and in this case it pretty much
killed black hair girl's only shot of
saving tosaki thanks to her eagerness
because let's face it if someone is
showing up and accusing you of [ __ ]
related to a jinns it's safe to say that
they would have implemented security
measures like bringing along their very
own ajin for situations like this one
these two made a fatal error and it's
going to cost them both of the ajin
girls look at each other in shock as
they both reveal their horrifying powers
to each other they battle it out but
this blonde lady is way better than
black hair girl kicking her ass and
badly wounding her before black hair
girl runs away at the last moment and
passes out and team blondie escapes with
tosaki in their car later at an unknown
location they begin their horrifying
plans to interrogate tosaki demanding to
know where the famous ajin doctor is
being kept but tosaki has some serious
moomin rider-sized balls and doesn't
tell them [ __ ] forcing blonde hair girl
to inject tosaki with a famous toxin and
this toxin is made especially for a
jinns and works by paralyzing the
diaphragm making the person feel like
they're slowly suffocating she stabs
tosaki as he quickly begins choking on
his own bravery and sits there
helplessly okay this is terrifying and
makes me think that team blondie here is
way more sadistic than their home landry
appearance makes it seem which is really
saying something now it seems as though
this toxin that blonde lady has is some
type of designer drug since the drug
name that she mentioned doesn't seem to
actually exist at least on paper but
like any such designer drug this one
seems to mimic the effects of such
toxins that disrupt the parasympathetic
nervous system or the system that
regulates bodily function automatically
tosaki's breathing was altered to make
him feel like he was suffocating to make
him feel like he was dying this likely
means that this drug interfered with his
heart's processes by inhibiting his
sympathetic nervous system blocking
neuromuscular transmissions and forcing
his diaphragm muscle to stop working
properly the likely drug similar to the
effects that tosaki was injected with
could have been through the use of a
toxin known as cure a toxin that can be
found in a class of plants and is a
poison used by amazon tribes centuries
prior this drug is a neurotoxin that
acts as a neuromuscular blocking agent
capable of blocking messages sent by the
body's central nervous system to control
the movement of muscle and was used for
medicinal purposes in the mid 19th
century as a muscle relaxant during
surgeries that required anesthesia this
toxin when administered improper dosages
can cause death by sphyxiation due to
the paralysis of the diaphragm very
similar right to how tosaki was affected
just now the dosage amount to use curare
within a safe range is so slim that
doctors don't even use this crap anymore
that's how dangerous this stuff is
however the effects from q rare can be
reversed with no consequence if the
dosages are small enough however since
team blondie is using this drug
willy-nilly with no other drugs to cure
tosaki of this toxin this makes me think
that they mixed this neurotoxin with
something else to offset the certainty
of death from this poison since they did
mention that this drug would not kill
tosaki only that it would make him feel
like he is dying very slowly back in the
parking lot blackhair girl finally wakes
up and runs back to tell the guy and the
rest of them what just happened she
tries to convince them to stop their
plan to save the minister in order to
save tosaki first and with a little
rough convincing she gets nagai and the
rest of the team to get on her side to
go save tosaki the ajin doctor also
tells them that he thinks he knows where
they're holding tosaki at a safe house
that they've used before and the gang
suits up to go save him meanwhile tosaki
continues to get brutally tortured as
nagai and his team bust into the same
warehouse and use their aegen powers and
tactics to defeat all of team blondie's
minions forcing these blonde bastards to
escape and the guy quickly sends his
agent to chase after them and puts a
tracker on their car causing a
terrifying car chase through the city
streets and the guy and crew try to
catch them before they head to the one
place in japan where they'll be safe
from them and the japanese government
the united states embassy flying down
narrow city streets the guy and crew
chase team blondie down black hair girl
takes a back road and surprises the two
and crashes into them head-on the two
escape but blackhair girl catches up but
still recovering doesn't have enough
strength to summon her black ghost she
tries to stop them herself but blonde
girl takes her out with her black ghost
and badly injures her again suddenly
black her girl gets so mad that somehow
she unleashes her black ghost destroying
blonde girls and black her girl shoots
blonde guy with a sleeping dart after
talking to each other blonde girl
decides to betray her master shooting
him while he's unconscious and walks
away blackhair girl in tosaki are
quickly then rescued by nagayan crew but
tosaki freaks out because he realizes
that if they're all here with him then
that means that the minister is by
himself he's all alone tosaki quickly
calls the minister assistant but he
tells them that they're too late that
sato has already killed the minister and
that sato left him alive to tell the
tale the group then heads back to their
safe house sad as hell and tosaki gives
up but suddenly nagai comes up with an
important update sato has just uploaded
another terrifying announcement online
sato through the camera lens tells the
world that he's killed almost everyone
on his kill list except one and that he
will kill his final target this ceo
exactly at this time three days from now
at this meeting the guy and crew freak
out and so does sato's minions confused
as hell they ask sato why he just
revealed to the world their plans but
sato tells them to relax that it makes
the game more fun because what sato has
planned will shock everyone on the news
the president of japan announces that
due to sato the government has just
officially sanctioned a new team to
protect the ceo and that meeting this
new team is called the anti-aging
special forces hand-picked and specially
trained to fight only ajins using the
latest weapon technology made by the
same company that this ceo runs musashi
industries the gang knows that these
guys don't have what it takes to take on
sato and so they also prepare for one
last fight against sato the government
is using an anti-aging special forces
unit to capture sato yeah it sounds good
on paper but we all know what happened
in season one sato has taken out a
special forces team before i get it
they're scared and on the brink of
losing their [ __ ] but really better
weapons is what is going to stop sato
this guy's avoided an entire government
hell-bent on getting him they're so
underestimating their opponent they
think they now have him beat with this
special forces unit sato knows they're
underestimating him which is why he
basically gave us and the government a
freebie by revealing his cards and
telling us exactly when he'll attack
next and where while on the surface this
looks simple but if we take a look past
sato we can instantly figure out that
this guy is straight up playing us
because the only reason you would ever
reveal your cards is if you're holding
something else up your sleeve and it's
clear that come on back in the past like
i said he's already done this before
he's already taken out a special forces
unit and he also snuck onto a plane and
brought a bomb while being the most
wanted person in all of japan and dare i
say the world there's no way he would
tell us all of this unless he had
something to compensate the fact that we
know when and where he's going to attack
what the government should do is take a
look at what has happened before he has
used a bomb in the past and bombs can be
made in all shapes and sizes and can be
used to take down buildings in a matter
of minutes and also if we take a look at
the mind of sato he's a jokester he's a
trickster he enjoys chaos and enjoys
doing it in the most grandiose way
possible which means for him it must be
some sort of spectacle and what could be
more devastating than a bomb taking out
an entire building the anti-aging
special forces unit terrifies sato's
crew but sato tells them to relax he has
a plan more sinister than ever back at
the base a guy and tosaki go over their
plan that will take place during the ceo
meeting in a few days where sato will
surely attack tosaki says that they are
only to attack sato if the antiogen
special forces fail to capture him then
and there because now that these special
forces guys are in the game tosaki's
people can't get in their way tosaki
then goes back to his headquarters and
convinces his boss to let his team help
out because no one knows what sato is
truly capable of a few days later the
day of the meeting arrives and tosaki's
team goes into the building sneaking the
guy and nakano in the whole of japan
prepares for sato just then a truck
suddenly pulls up and the cops surround
it they open the back of the truck and
see a massive device attached to a
laptop in the distance sato through the
camera on the laptop stares at the cops
surrounding the truck and presses a
button suddenly a massive explosion
erupts destroying everything and
everyone nearby and the power everywhere
suddenly goes out the general tells
everybody that they've just been hit
with an emp bomb capable of shutting
down all electronics nearby suddenly
drones come flying in and dive down into
the crowd of cops exploding on impact
and sato repels down and into the
building and the fight begins it's a
chaotic bloodbath sato's right-hand man
this long-haired guy then calls his
black ghost to take the soldiers out
brutally tearing them apart but then he
gets shot and losing all hope until sato
finally comes out from hiding and he's
pissed he then goes hand to hand with
these two guys and beats them with ease
moving with more precision and skill
than anyone this group has ever seen and
they quickly get overwhelmed and
defeated sato's team then heads up the
stairs and they get fired upon again but
this time isn't a guy's crew and the two
teams carry on the firefight sato slips
behind them and enters the conference
room but finds nagai holding the ceo
hostage the guy then blames sato for
ruining his life and tells him to drop
his weapon or else and sato agrees then
suddenly these two shoot at sato with
tranquilizers but they get blocked by
his black ghost sato smiles wide but
then gets shot by a third tranquilizer
isn't a guy's black ghost from above
sato then plops down to the floor and
the gang celebrates because a black
ghost is only deadly if the ajin is
awake to control it but they don't
realize what hell they've just caused
because suddenly blackhair girl gets
shot and they realize that sato's black
ghost is still moving while sato is
unconscious the guy then trembles in
fear as he gets knocked down by sato's
ghost and it kills sato and brings him
back to life good as new the guy then
looks on in sheer terror as sato busts
out the front door and begins shooting
and the guy's team that is still
fighting against sato's crew and the guy
badly injured can do nothing but watch
as sato takes out his teammates one by
one and sato returns and prepares to cut
in a guy's head off just like he
promised way back when just then a
military helicopter shows up forcing
sato and his team to back off and make a
getaway well that went well not the guy
from the get-go should have thought that
if he was capable of controlling his
black ghost while unconscious then
probably he wasn't the only aegen who
could do this and of all legends sato
with his experience could probably have
been capable of doing the same thing and
also the ajin doctor is partially to be
blamed for this because someone is
capable as sato should have had some
form of record on file we know that sato
was in the military before which means
that he had to have had some sort of
record on file they put way too much
faith in their assumption that sato
wasn't capable of what nagai is because
as we can clearly see he was the guy
gets captured by the military and sato
and his team escape and sato even kills
the ceo shocking his whole team but sato
then says that this ceo wouldn't have
granted their kind any civil rights and
that they'll have to put on a big show
in order to get what they want and
sato's team opens up this weaponized
vault in preparation for what's to come
but these guys have no idea just how
truly insane sato really is back on the
ground tosaki's team catches a breather
and goes all self-defeated for a second
until tosaki puts his boss this glasses
guy to sleep and freezing the guy and
nakano and everyone escapes back at the
base tosaki blames all of this crap on a
guy and tosaki tells the whole team to
give up the guy goes and cries in his
room for a little bit as sato goes on
the news and reveals that his kill list
is over and that within 10 days he'll
begin the final wave and that he plans
to seriously negotiate with the
government this time the next day sato's
team reaches this military compound in
trucks and he shoots these two guys as
more and more trucks enter and that's
when the chaos begins a wave of these
undetend warriors began sweeping this
base and kill every single last soldier
to be seen and they quickly overtake the
base's armory and sato then makes
another live broadcast saying that one
week from today all nanojins in japan
must evacuate this country and he's
going to turn this place into purely an
ajin territory and if they don't he'll
use these weapons to kill everyone
tosaki and his team see sato's madness
live and agree to try and take him out
one last time back at the president of
japan's office they go over the
situation and discuss what sato has and
what he's truly capable of okay this is
nuts and this proves that sato is
certifiably crazy these missiles that
sato is threatening to destroy japan
with contain nerve agents also known as
nerve gas which is a class of organic
chemical that disrupts the mechanisms by
which nerves transfer messages to organs
hence the name nerve gas because death
by one of these can occur within minutes
and it works by ensuring death by
respiratory arrest through the effect it
has on the diaphragm paralyzing it and
also affecting the area of the brainstem
that controls breathing known as the
respiratory center this weapon is
basically a neurotoxin on roids and even
a low dose of it from one of these bad
boys can ensure that his victims
experience a variety of neurological and
mental disorders from loss of memory
mental confusion and cognitive problems
sato killed almost every single person
on his kill list he knowingly killed
every person that was capable of having
the laws change in order to grant their
aegen kind rights he murdered that
minister from earlier that guy could
have helped sato enact laws that could
have helped ajins the fact that he
killed him means he had no intention of
making an agreement with the government
there was way less extreme measures that
he could have taken in order to get what
he wanted i have two options for the
government one give tosaki actually full
governmental support and resources that
will make their efforts in getting to
sato much easier or option two vaporize
the compound right now let's see how
well ajin survive a land to air missile
go ahead let the chemical weapons get
destroyed because if the missile blast
doesn't incinerate the entire area and
the chemicals that nerve gas paralyzes
the diaphragm right our breathing muscle
then wouldn't that mean that most of
jinns wouldn't be able to wake back up
and even if they did they would
suffocate and pass out and that's if
they survived the blast which i highly
doubt i believe the combined destruction
of military-grade weapons and buildings
would kill everybody and anybody in the
area back at the armory sato licks his
lips at everything going on and the
government contacts them and tells sato
that they're willing to work with them
and that they're willing to make some
japanese islands nearby an official ajin
nation and this gets all the other
agents excited as hell but then sato
spits in their face and does the
craziest thing ever he launches the
nerve gas missiles launching it right
near the president's office killing two
people and horrifying everyone else even
the ajin and he tells everyone that they
now have three days to evacuate japan or
else sato's crew finally thinks he's too
crazy but sato threatens to cut off
their heads if they don't follow his
orders and they realize that sato
doesn't give a damn about their future
all he cares about is the thrill of
battle and so his crew decides to sneak
away through the sewers and head towards
the one person they know who could help
them nagai at the president's office
they decide to release poison gas
through underground tunnels near the
armory and around that area killing
everyone innocent and guilty nearby
sato's crew caused nagai and asks to
meet they tell him that they want to
join the team and are willing to help
nagai take sato down and in return they
ask for their freedom both sides agree
to work together and they even tell
tosaki where sato is hiding and everyone
heads to tosaki's base and he goes over
the battle plan they plan to capture
sato before the military releases the
poison gas but nagai has an idea this is
all a game to sato which means that sato
has a weakness they can use later on
sato and longhair dudes sit and wait and
they then get an alert that someone is
coming and sato gets ready for the
incoming military but just nagai shows
up surprising sato and pissing him off
because no one gets between him and his
games the guy calls out his black ghost
but gets defeated quickly by sato and
the team quickly runs away within a guy
calling on multiple black ghosts to slow
down sato as they lead him right here
sato aims his sights on the group when
all of a sudden an explosion erupts and
the guy tells him that they plan to bury
him alive right here and now but sato is
one step ahead of them and takes out his
own phone and detonates his own bomb
nearby burying everyone instead okay
look these guys were at the end of their
rope and they almost had sato dead to
rights the guy here is the smartest of
the lot sure but boy did he act dumb
here this is the one time where they
could have outsmarted sato and allowed
him no backup plan because at this point
we know sato always has a backup plan we
have to make sure sato doesn't think he
needs to trigger his backup plan until
it's too late at the last moment the guy
chose to go the route of every james
bond villain ever and comment on how he
was going to get to sato rather than
just saying nothing and blowing the
whole place up to hell we could have
even had nakano go fight him head on and
continuously keep sato busy and not
realize what we are about to do because
think about this this orange hair bozo
has a heart full of gold and is the
sweetest of the bunch yes but he's also
the strongest of us here and the fit
tests that tosaki put us through showed
that he is faster stronger than a guy is
the guy should have risked permanently
killing nakano if that meant he could
have distracted sato up until the last
moment the gang wakes up scattered and
injured trapped underground and sato
wants to play one last game with them
all like her girl is terrified as her
black ghost tries to slow down sato but
nothing can stop him he kills this guy
and closes in on her like her girl done
running decides to face sato herself but
gets shot by sato with ease he even
prepares to kill this girl but nagai's
black ghost stops him no one can do
anything and sato beats them all cutting
off nakano's hand and beating the [ __ ]
out of the guy and long-haired guy then
shows up to help sato he tries to kill
black hair girl just as nakano's black
ghost stops him distracting him just
long enough until blackhair girl shoots
him with a sleeping dart making him pass
out nearby nagai now out of energy backs
up as sato prepares to cut off his head
staring death in the face suddenly
causes the guy to release a flood of
black ghosts everywhere killing sato and
chopping off his head defeating him the
government arrives to capture sato with
tosaki showing up with the agreement to
let these aegen kids remain under his
control and the group goes back to their
normal lives little do they realize sato
isn't done and he escapes with
long-haired dude these two ain't done
with terrifying japan and they prepare
for their second playthrough but what do
you guys think about ajin season 2 let
us know what you liked and what you
didn't like don't forget to leave a
thumbs up and also don't forget to check
out our how to beat videos